We ALL know the penis is a sensitive organ,
and yet there are many who choose cut off
a chunk of their kids' manhood -- but what
does this DO to
the penis?
The practice of circumcision dates back thousands
of years, popping up in ancient cultures in
Asia, Africa, Australia and the Americas independently,
before any knew the other existed.
It's practiced in Muslim, Christian and Jewish
populations.
Worldwide rates vary, but in the U.S. from
1980 to 1999, 65 percent of babies were cut,
and today, it's closer to 56 percent; rates
have been falling since 1960.
Nationally, three out of four babies getting
the procedure in the Midwest, two thirds in
the Northeast, a little over half in the south,
and only a fifth in the West!
Circumcision is the act of slicing the foreskin
off the penis.
A natural penis has skin covering its head,
but a circumcised one does not.
A DiscoveryNews.com article describes the
foreskin as an "eyelid for the penis," which
is a weird analogy but they are similar in
that there’s a mucous membrane on the inside.
The adult foreskin is about 12 square inches,
of skin containing specialized nerve endings.
From a sexual standpoint, circumcision removes
one third of the erogenous tissue of the male
genetalia -- as the penis and clitoris come
from the same fetal tissue, the analogous
organ to the foreskin is the clitoral hood!
Obviously, there is a TON of debate as to
the real benefit of circumcision; and it doesn't
help that the policies keep shifting.
In 1999, the American Academy of Pediatrics
issued a statement calling the practice into
question, saying the risks didn't outweigh
the benefits, but now a new compilation study
done by the Mayo Clinic claims the benefits
outweigh the risks 100 to 1!
According to their findings, over their lifetime
half of all men will require some kind of
foreskin-related medical attention; circumcision
reduces risks of "urinary tract infection,
prostate cancer, sexually transmitted diseases"
and the risk of cervical cancer is reduced
for the female partners of cut men.
In fact, the World Health Organization recommend
the procedure for any country attempting to
battle HIV infection.
Now you might be thinking, wait, the United
Nation's World Health Organization has a pruned
penis policy?
Yeah, it does.
And a 2010 study from Plos ONE explains why…
See, the foreskin isn't just an extra bit
on the bits.
Because the foreskin is a protective, mucous-membrane
layer, it also attracts bacteria -- actually,
according to the study, the foreskin has it's
own microbiome!
For the study, researchers from Johns Hopkins
Bloomberg School of Public Health looked under
the hood of uncircumcised penises, and found
anaerobic bacteria, those are bacteria which
live without oxygen.
Studying Ugandan men before and after circumcision,
they discovered, that this previously unknown
anaerobic bacteria disappeared in the year
they were cut; forever altering the individual
microbiome of the male penis.
It is known from other studies that Langerhans
cells normally live under the foreskin as
well, and are commonly attacked by HIV, so
perhaps that's why HIV transmission is so
much lower with circumcised men?
They're still figuring this out.
In the end, the practice is ancient and fascinating,
but is it necessary?
Not at all, and there's still a roaring debate
about removing a third of the penile erogenous
tissue, issues of cleanliness, not to mention
possible side-effects the major trauma!